back to binge battle i am your host mark
ellis thanks for joining us today if
you've seen the show before you know
it's a spirited i don't even like to use
the word debate because we're really
just here celebrating some sort of
property that we know and love in this
case it's some of the old and some of
the new because the witcher premiered on
netflix in 2019 with everyone's favorite
shredded muscle head well besides me
henry cavill playing the title role of
well he plays gerald and then we have a
lot of monsters we have a lot of friends
we have a lot of foes and some people
are both as we meet them along the way
and i use the word people loosely
because there's a crap ton of monsters
in this show as well it's a whole lot of
fun season two is just about to debut on
netflix it's gonna be sometime this
month and so we thought let's talk about
the witcher because that's the new of it
the old is that it is based on a series
of best-selling novels that go way way
back and so we are here to talk about it
with two of my friends and we all go way
way back in this community and so i am
thrilled to bring into the show that
could be at least four rounds probably
going to be five rounds you know her as
that girl trish online but you also know
her as a
gaming fan a tech fan she covers all of
it for tv internet and everywhere in
between and all corners of cyberspace
the one the only this tricia hershberger
trisha welcome to binge battle how are
you kid
i am so excited to be on binge battles
talking about the witcher today i
brought my medallion
i'm like so ready to go i just binged
the season one in its entirety to get
ready for season two i love the books i
love the games and i'm so excited to be
here today thank you for having me it's
just good to see your face it is great
to see your face your wonderful witcher
medallion and i was going to ask you did
you come to the show like when it
dropped on netflix where you're like oh
this seems like something i could get
into and then you went back and looked
at all the books and video games and all
that stuff or did you were you like a
huge fan of this property as far back as
you can remember and now we have a tv
show to talk about as well
uh so i'm a games fan first
and then from the games got into the
books and then from the books got into
the series um but i kind of did books
and series hand in hand and like a
parallel i started the books probably oh
a year or so before we got the netflix
series so i'm i'm in the books like just
ahead of where the series is at all
times as i'm watching it um but i i love
the witcher world i love the continent
you know in all of its formats and i i
honestly this is one of my favorite
series to talk about adaptation because
i think each of the different mediums
brought something new to it and enhanced
the overall fandom in some way
and just so long as i can have your word
now before we get into the scoring and
the debate portion of the show when the
magic the gathering series drops can you
would you come back to binge battle and
we can talk because i know you and i are
both huge fans
yes 100 i would love to do that i'm a
huge magic fan
all right the the booking has been
attained and so now we meet your other
very special guest today the
founder and owner of geekbomb she covers
everything in the world of entertainment
you've seen her on tv and online one of
my dear friends with one of her friends
at her feet i believe is maude garrett
mod is the puppy in the room she is i
can confirm zelda is i have like a
floofy little bed for her under the desk
because she likes to be by my side the
problem is sometimes i wonder if her
snores pick up on the microphone so i'm
a little bit concerned
and i have the same fear as you with
molly the wonder dog who is currently
snoozing over yonder so i don't think
we're hearing any dog although you one
of the last times we actually got to see
each other in person was at the dog park
where uh zelda and molly frequent and
they became fast friends and so that
made me feel happy and so now we get to
see each other again after all these
many years we've worked together on and
off talking about the witcher were you
on the netflix trainer were you already
on the book train well before the series
was ever announced listen i'm on the
henry cavill train that's for sure uh
but i will say like trisha i mean he's
my hall pass am i allowed to say that
wait i'm not married so
bring it on
here's a goal um i will say definitely a
fan of the game witcher 3 got game of
the year and then i think it kind of
kept getting game of the year even
though it wasn't even out that year i
have played it all the way through twice
it was my covert cleanser as i call it
because i know it was a good time and i
know i had fun playing it so i was like
it had been about three or four years
and i was able to play it again as if it
was for the first time so when the
series came out on netflix with henry
cavill i was like oh chef's kiss really
enjoyed that because of the the time
jumps though i went to the book because
i do feel like more often than not the
book is always going to be better than
the show or the television or the movie
because it explains things in better
detail and so i actually listened to the
book series i found the narrator to be
questionable and uh trisha and i
actually spoke at length about the book
trisha liked the book a lot more than i
did just because of this dang narrator
but in terms of sort of like the it's
like a series of short stories for the
last wish um and i really enjoyed that i
didn't keep listening to the series
though i kind of stopped after the first
one but i'm super super pumped for
season two of the witcher and the fact
that henry cavill loves playing geralt
so much and he's like i'm absolutely
invested into seven seasons of this show
makes me even more excited about it all
yeah it seems like we might be seeing
him a lot more as geralt than maybe him
as that other character that he's famous
for playing and so we're about to get
into it right now here on binge battle
here's how it works like i said we have
four rounds each round is a different
topic of debate for our two expert
panelists talking about the witcher i
will at the end of the day have to
betray my friendship to either mod or
attrition by awarding a point to the
other person but again it's all just fun
and shenanigans here if we end up tied
after four rounds two to two we will go
to a fifth round tie breaker and if
you're a fan of binge bout you know that
does happen quite often here on the show
as well as spoilers of plenty so if
you've not yet seen the witcher series
on netflix or played through any of the
video games or read any of the books or
the short stories you may want to do
some research before you or maybe this
debate will get you into the witcher and
so i would really think either way
you're going to be just fine here as we
have fun talking about the witcher
season two about to drop on netflix so
if we are ready to go here i say we get
right into it with round one i'm hearing
a lot of henry henry cavill
rightfully so because he's great as
guerrelle but i'm going to be
disappointing both of y'all because
round number one is your favorite
character you're not allowed to say girl
so it's got to be somebody else mod
garrett i'm going to start with you
round one
your favorite character one minute on
the clock it has to be yaskia who in the
books in the show i mean in the game is
called dandelion but in this particular
iteration it is yaskia the sidekick that
joined our favorite mutant on the
adventure and what better sidekick to
have to a monosyllabic beast hunter
that barely utters a word
it has to be the bard that won't shut up
they are such a good combination i love
their dynamic together and i truly think
that yaskiya brings so much to this duo
uh you have to admit at the end of the
day um geralt is a you know paid for
hire beast hunter and in that day and
age there's no internet ads it is all
word of mouth but because geralt hardly
speaks he's not really advocating what
he does
so enter yaskia who realizes that this
is just all about marketing and he is a
one-man marketing team that's very good
at his job and by creating all of these
songs to explain the heroics of what
geralt does
he actually makes geralt's reputation so
much higher and more in demand and with
those powers combined can make a lot
more money
geralt is also a lone wolf uh he's spent
a lot of time traveling on his own and
he doesn't really let people into his
life he's not capable of human emotion
including usually like trust and love
and yet yasuki managed to win him over
really quickly um even though geralt's
kind of like you're a little annoying
and you do talk a lot he really kind of
forged to this loyalty and bond with
geralt to the point that whenever
yaski's reputation is on the line his
safety's on the line or his life is on
the line geralt goes above and beyond
the call of duty to protect his newfound
best friend and that's something that's
kind of out of the structure of a a
witcher which is everything has its
price and they usually don't do a damn
thing to get their hands dirty unless
there's gold on the table so for geralt
to go um you know to balls attend balls
uh that yaski is playing at to step in
in case someone gets angry at him
for whatever reason we we don't know
um
whatever it is like geralt's going to be
there like he made a deal with jennifer
to save yasuki's life was he the one
that risked his life yes but he's you
know making sure that he's saving his
life as well
uh and also just from like a watching
the show point of view i felt that there
was such good balance and that it breaks
the tension and yaski is humor is just
so delightful for the show and if you
didn't have toss a coin to your witch uh
the song in your head for days weeks if
not months after that show
you know the guy can sing yaski's got a
set of pipes on him that is just every
time he sings whether it's accompanied
or just you know
on his own it's just delightful
so that's why yaski is my favorite
character it's a hell of a performance
by the wonderful joey beatty you're kind
of describing the life of a comic on the
road here you just go around you don't
really say too much so you need somebody
to hype you up we could all use the ask
here in our lives but now we go to
trisha hershberger who has her favorite
character in the witcher not name girl
who you got not name girl uh no um i
love yasker don't get me wrong but for
me my favorite character of the series
has to be jennifer she is so very human
and layered and i'm not just talking
about the transformation we see happen
with her but i'm talking about every
step of the way even after she gets that
power and that new found look right that
comes with that like when we see her
frustrated and jealous as she's
traveling with queen kayla's i believe
kayla's or callus um and the baby and
she's traveling with her and feeling
like this this jealousy and this kind of
yes she's learned the political game but
all of this power hasn't delivered on
the promise that she hoped that it would
and then the assassin spoiler alerts if
you haven't seen season one she's
traveling with the queen and the baby
assassin comes in and we watch jennifer
go through do i even want to save her
okay it's my job i will but then when
she turns when the queen turns super
jerky uh you know then we watch jennifer
go through this very very complicated
um kind of mind screw if you will of
fine i guess i don't want to save her ah
but the baby's innocent all right i'll
try to save the baby and then we watch
her go through this roller coaster of
emotions as she is you know trying her
best and using all her power but
realizing that as powerful as she is in
some ways and in my opinion it's you
know herself getting in the way a lot of
the time she's not quite as infallible
as she thinks she is and she goes
through many moments like that
throughout the books throughout the
games throughout the series where we are
learning who she is with her and i think
this kind of rollercoaster of
consequences that we get to watch feels
very real and very human um i also think
anya chalotra and i hope i said her last
name correctly mud could probably
correct me on that one i think that she
nails the versatility of yen and the
power of yen and the vulnerability of
yen all at the same time which is no
easy feat and i know going into the
series a lot of people were really
nervous about that um to kind of see how
that would be handled i also really like
the character of jennifer because i'm
someone who is very very into dark
fantasy lore and having your magic users
specifically be incredibly powerful in
multiple ways and yen is that she's
equally as powerful in a battle of wits
as she is in combat and you know you
might go into this series if you don't
know anything about the witcher thinking
that geralt is the one who's going to
win all of the physical combat hands
down but i mean at the battle of sodom
hill we watch jennifer take down the
entire nilfgaardian army solo like she
is
not to be messed with and she has no
qualms taking on damage herself to get
stuff done which also as a woman who
likes to get stuff done i can appreciate
in jennifer that she's like whatever i
have to do to make sure that like i am
the queen in this moment right now and i
am the all-powerful one like
book fans know that jennifer is
basically like jean grey with dark
phoenix inside
and i think in this series we are now uh
you know just getting to the cusp like
at the end of season one we're just
getting to the cusp where that's
becoming unleashed and i can't wait to
see
what happens with season two i also want
to throw in there and probably out of
time but i also want to throw in there
with jennifer that she's politically
super aware and powerful as well so not
just kind of the wits and the
manipulation that's on that side not
just the physical combat but also
politically very strategic she's very
powerful she knows how to play the game
she's been doing it for a really long
time and she is sassy
she comes back with those clips um and
you know sometimes sometimes too a fault
she's manipulative and sassy but we we
get to see her heart underneath that
stony exterior and
for me when i look at the series as a
whole and i think what really embodies
this world of the witcher um what
characters do a really good job of
showcasing us who that is i think
yen and geralt are kind of the yin to
each other's yang and so if i have to
choose a character that's not daryl i'm
going annifer
hey everyone welcome back to binge
battle let's see more of what our guests
had to say about today's topic
yeah i would say jennifer probably be
really good on this show as well and if
she was playing magic the gathering
she'd probably be a fan of the black and
blue deck so let's go back over to you
mod garrett just a quick rebuttal rounds
here 30 seconds or less for each of you
you can stump for um
for your
character choice more you can go against
your opponent a little bit mod garrett
how do you want to take it so i'm
actually from the video games there's a
big debate are you team yen or team tris
i was always without a fault team yen
but not in this show she is so
selfish she is so self-centered she's so
hungry for power that once she gets a
taste for it she's willing to even
sacrifice parts of herself in like a
moment of where hindsight doesn't exist
to try and obtain that power she is
manipulative she is politically based
but it's all for her own gain she's
willing to try to possess a gin so that
she can get wishes to even further her
own gain the fact that geralt had to say
to her she's not a good mom which i have
to agree with because she killed a baby
and she killed her mother to get the
baby she tried to save the baby that
baby died in her care and she her number
one job was to protect this queen and
because the assassin was too hard she's
like you know what i can actually
dispose of this woman so i can steal her
baby and the baby still died this is a
woman who should not be having children
she should not be in the care of anyone
else she will protect herself first
every single time and she's not a good
person to even geralt so i don't think
this version of yen is my girl and i
don't i can't support her and she's
absolutely not my favorite all right i
know she's a quarter elf but mod saying
just a bad overall human being here so
uh trisha do you want you want to defend
uh yeah yeah a little bit more do you
want to talk about mods character choice
it's up to you
uh well i mean i would say to say that
she killed the queen and killed the baby
is an incredible oversimplification of
everything that goes on in that scene so
i will definitely leave it at that and
ask you the viewers who are watching
this to please re-watch that scene on
your own and not just take mod's word
for that one uh when it comes to yes
year it's so easy to say the comic
relief guy is my favorite character
especially when you're in a dark fantasy
world i do love yes here when you're
talking about favorite character of the
series to me it's about which character
really says this is this is the witcher
like a character that you can look at
and say i am fully engrossed in this
world i know this world i know where
we're going with this story and yaskir
is such a sideline character on that
that it's hard to argue that that is
that character and i will again just
because mod tore down jennifer in such a
mean way what did jennifer do to you mod
but i will go again that there is a
heart in anya chalotra's portrayal of
this character underneath and i think
what mod was speaking to is that icy
cold exterior that we see in the front
and the way we see a lot in the early
episodes of season one but definitely
not where we end up and i do think uh
you know when it comes to acting what
you're really looking for there are
multiple levels and to kind of straw man
that performance to just one of those
levels is unfair to anya all right so we
got some got some heat coming now this
is good stuff so now we just have a
closing sort of
statement here from each of you i know
it's tough to take all of these
arguments just summarize it nice and
succinctly mod garrett you're up first
uh the question is the favorite
character and the comic relief who is
fun who lifts up geralt who is you know
the one who sings and is jovial and is
fun and great that's what a favorite is
all about this isn't the best written
character the character with the biggest
growth it's none of those things it's a
favorite character and because of yen's
our initial kind of
thirst for power in a way that hurts
many many other people and she's so
tunnel visioned in a negative way that
she doesn't score a favorite uh title
for me it has to be yaskia who is hands
down the favorite character
all right favorite character for trisha
was yen so you have the last word in
round one
when you go to watch or read or play the
witcher you are not going to find a com
a comedic sitcom that's not why you're
going to the series you are going to
this series for power you are going to
this series for darkness for moral gray
areas and battles and yennefer really
embodies that this is why i love hosting
the show and now the all the pressure's
on me and this is the hardest part for
me is because i got to pick between
these two great arguments and so if i'm
looking at who
my favorite character is that was the
question favorite character and so iasca
are obviously a great choice just
because you need some sort of levity in
this show as i like saying there's not
going to be a lot of slipping on banana
peels in the witcher but you just want
some yucks where you can get them and so
you ask you're certainly providing some
of that light but as far as a favorite
character goes it could also be
interpreted as who is the character that
has the most to them that has the most
layers that has the most interesting
emotional depth who has the most promise
of future adventures and so if the
show's called the witcher as much as
even this it feels like i'm rolling
against myself here i i love a good
comic relief it's kind of made how i
made a living but i think that i have to
go with my favorite character being the
more interesting character and so i'm
with y'all if i can't pick her out i'm
probably going slightly towards yennefer
and having said that i probably am never
going to get to hang with you ask your
in real life which which really which
really kills me to my core but i'm going
to go
with yennefer in round one so trisha
gets on the board gets the point and we
are off and running here on the winter
binge back i have to say though you know
it's such a matter of personal
preference right absolutely we could all
sit down and watch any show and have
three different favorite characters just
based on our personality and what we
seek out of our entertainment so that i
feel like was a really subjective one
and very well argued on mod's part i'm
about to defend jennifer in about three
questions
hey everyone welcome back to binge
battle let's see more of what our guests
had to say about today's topic
well that's what we're here to do and so
if you thought it was tough to pick your
favorite character then i'm just gonna
throw another one at you because we're
going to round two with our favorite
monster favorite monster trisha you won
round number one so i'm gonna give you
the honor you get to kick off in round
two your favorite monster in a minute or
less okay my favorite monster in this
series specifically is the dragon and i
know people are gonna say oh every
fantasy story someone's gotta love a
dragon because dragons are like where
it's at i have dragons on my wall behind
me like obviously i'm a big fan but why
i picked the dragon for the netflix
series season one specifically is
because yes we all know dragons are
really fantastic in literature and
fantasy generally but to see one of the
most intelligent of the species the gold
dragon take human form imports to
journey with and get to know
geralt and the entire party
all in this master plan of protecting
his youth was super cool to see now you
guys are going to start to realize that
i have a very specific character type
that i'm drawn to and it's like the very
intellectual complexity manipulative
powerful characters um so much of the
same as jennifer but this is what i like
uh so i feel like when we see the gold
dragon in this series we're seeing not
only like a conniving cultivating plan
of very very many intricate steps and
like predicting the future of what
people are gonna do but he also has like
the ability to do exactly that like
determine and potentially influence the
whims of his companions to do his will
um he also
absolutely knows his strength and at any
point in all of that could have just
dragging it out murderballed everybody
and then his youth are totally protected
but that's not how he wants to play it
he doesn't need to throw around his
power
to achieve his goals it's understated
it's smart and it's ridiculously
overpowered and that's why i chose the
dragon for favorite monster in the
witcher season one in any fantasy store
you gotta have a dragon in there
somewhere so maud you're a counter to
the dragon i know tricia loves dragons
her fans are called the dragon riders um
i will say though when you look at the
plethora of beasts and monsters that
show up in the witcher i find the most
frightening is actually not the biggest
and the baddest it's the doppler and a
doppler is a body switcher
um and i think what's so
interesting about body switches and body
swappers in this particular instance is
this political intrigue you have a key
player that can become
anybody
in the games and in the books you'll
have people that they are mercenaries so
if you've got the gold they will do thy
bidding and become whether it's a
relative whether it's someone in um a
regal sense anyone that you want to
murder you can replace them with someone
the power that you can have with a
doppler is almost endless and i think
the scariest part is as soon as they
take on the form of who they're going to
become
it isn't just a physical swap they also
adopt every single memory that that
person has ever had from the moment
leading up to that swap so i think that
you know when you look at the body swap
or the body snatcher as a whole
it's this uh thing in in literature or
in whatever it is in fiction where if
it's happening you you ask a question to
try and determine if they know the
answer because if it's something sort of
unique then it's like that has to be
them okay cool
but the doppler has all that information
so they can absolutely accurately and
convincingly become another person and
have their entire memories to back that
up and to make that transition flawless
and i think in this in this sense where
mouse mousetrap uh mouse mouse hunt what
was his name mousey who is the only
person that siri trusted pretty much in
the world
the doppler was able to become him to
lure siri out of an impenetrable forest
fortress
to take her to the enemy and i think
that when you when you kind of really
scratch your brain and think of how you
can use a doppler or what a doppler
could do
uh for survival to live to mess with
politics in war you name it i think they
are
the most frightening but my favorite
monster and how the witcher law has just
adapted that to make it even more
powerful to me is my favorite all right
maud garrett you heard it here first
somehow
forcing me to trust humanity even less
than i already do so it is one we got it
we got a doppler we got a dragon here
it's a nice wide swath of monsters so
trisha you get a 30 second rebuttal
either stumping for the dragon or going
against the doppler me neither because
the doppler i mean the doppler is
awesome so i'm gonna yes mod the doppler
is awesome i was trying to fact check
over here on the side whether or not
they copy all the memories and
apparently that is hotly debated in the
uh in the witcher fandom because i had
not heard that but i was like that's
super cool if that's true and then some
people are like oh they only copy recent
memories not old memories and that's how
you can catch and find out that it's a
doppler um so that that's hotly debated
but dopplers are super rad most dopplers
uh and you could say that this adds to
the argument or takes away from it
depending what you're looking for in
your favorite monster most dopplers are
very gentle and kind natured so
generally in the universe of the witcher
dopplers are not really considered a
threat because they're kind-hearted
wonderful peaceful little creatures um
that is true uh but the one that we
encounter in the series obviously is not
uh there are some that we encounter but
it's a it's a more rare thing i do like
i said i do think dopplers are really
cool i think strikers are really cool i
think as fans of the witcher in any of
its formats you get
introduced to a lot of these really
awesome creatures but for me the
favorites got to be the dragon just
because of the way that it's portrayed
and seeing kind of the the complete
understatedness
of the power and and how many chess
moves ahead the gold dragon is from the
rest of our party who by the way are not
nitwits the rest of our party we've got
geralt we've got yen we've got yaskaw
we've got all these other troops we've
got the dwarves we've got all of these
people in this adventuring party
and our golden dragon is like
50 steps ahead of them at every turn and
to me that was just so interesting and
fascinating to watch play out it was
cool to watch it play out watch it play
out when i read the books it was cool to
watch it play out in the series um and
and i just think it's a really nice
world informing uh creature for us to
get to experience
all right uh mod you can you can open
your argument by saying that most
dragons are cute and cuddly as i want
them to be i don't know if they are but
i want them to be that with the with the
whole dopplers are notoriously cute and
uh innocent that's not true they are
hunted because they can be exploited and
because they are so dangerous and a lot
of the time the doppler is just trying
to survive but because some of them
actually know their worth they use that
exploitation to absolutely make bank
speaking of bank i love tricia says i
love how this dragon's depicted same an
old white rich guy that's how i love my
dragons too
flanked by two women doing his bidding
he's really representing that dragon
also geralt totally uh nift the
the
rumor about the fertility if you get a
dragon's heart it will able to help with
fertility which is the only reason why
yennefer's there in the first place
geralt quickly nip that in the bud as it
is false and not true
so the heart can't even help so that was
no good as well uh also dragons are
super rare in this world and episode six
was my least favorite um and it
basically says that it proves that if
you need to deal with a dragon there's
there isn't a shortage of people that
are willing to take care of it so people
want to kill the dragon
this doesn't mean that it's my favorite
out of all the out of all the dragons
out there we're talking maleficent we're
talking all the different dragons
this is the most underwhelming one it
felt like a hercules episode but now we
do kareem into final argument time going
first to trisha the lover of dragons um
i i am the lover of dragons but honestly
i just think seeing a gold dragon
portrayed in a way that he's like 45
steps ahead of everyone else whether he
chooses to take human form as a male or
a female is irrelevant to me he can take
human form um and also just a quick fact
check there from the fandom wiki on the
doppler dopplers are exceptionally kind
and gentle beings in general for whom
the ability of metamorphosis serves as
compensation for lack of aggression
fangs and claws
doing some fact checking there's
probably some little things going on in
the doppler and look i'm kind of gentle
i can be bought too so uh mod garrett
you have the last word in round two for
dopplers trish is just making my
argument the fact that dopplers can be
used and exploited and absolutely change
the shift in politics in any sense they
are so clever and dangerous and they're
able to absorb memories of the person
they're taking over and they're really
sweet and lovely
thank you for making that point for me
it definitely makes them even better and
my favorite
sweet and lovely can certainly be
manipulated to a point and again look i
i don't want to beat anybody over the
head with magic the gathering references
but we have vesuvian doppelganger then
we have shivan dragon two of the best
rare cards from the revised edition
who do you take well dragon i mean you
can overpower with force but i like
trish's argument that this dragon is
also overpowering with their ability to
think
steps and steps ahead of human
counterparts but whereas the dragon can
use force or can use some strategy
mod depicting the doppler as just this
conniving i think the exact phrasing
that won me over was just the political
implications of what that could mean if
you were pretending to be somebody
regardless whether you get their entire
spectrum of memories or it's more of
like a herbal substance short-term
memory sort of thing you still get some
valuable information and you can
faithfully impersonate somebody much to
a mischievous end and so as fascinating
as we all are with dragons in every
fantasy or going back through the ages
i'm going doppler as the best
monster-ish even though they're cute and
they're cuddly and most of them mean
well i'm going doppler for favorite
monster in round two start all the
dopplers watching that i called you
monsters it's a very broad term uh it
can be good or bad
hey everyone welcome back to binge
battle let's see more of what our guest
had to say about today's topic it's one
to one here and we got us a ball game
folks we're going right into round at
number three which is your favorite
episode what is the best episode of
season one mod gara we are gonna start
with you and i have a feeling you're not
going to say episode 6. no that was the
weakest one um no for me it is the
season finale episode 8 called much more
this episode literally takes all of the
seven episodes the different timelines
all of the history the characters that
we're learning about and puts them all
together in an epic battle not just a
sword fight there there is an epic sword
fight but we are talking a full-on
battle if you like two towers on uh lord
of the rings because of that incredible
battle this is what you get here and not
only do we have the soldiers but we have
majors and we are finally seeing a group
of mages at their full potential and
seeing all that different types of magic
when just previously we'd seen a little
spell here and there we'd seen a portal
be created we saw a rock float we are
now seeing what mages are capable of and
it is brilliant and it is brutal not
only that but we get geralt's history we
realize who he is he has a mother who
was a sorceress why the law of surprise
was the reason why he became a witcher
in the first place the fact that he
hasn't mended that we're really honing
in on what destiny is and what destiny
means which has been a running theme
that some people haven't grasped hello
clancy
but i think that knowing geralt's
passed
seeing this gigantic battle come to head
with many players on the chessboard
moving and you know showing what they're
capable of the different types of magic
the fact that we had uh is it venic vena
goth or something vinegar whatever his
name is he can regenerate his sword so
he'll throw it and then he'll you know
summon another one little things like
that but we've got tris who's building
uh she get had the mushrooms explode out
into the forest with the poisonous
sporous gas that killed a bunch of them
and died like another woman just had
them all crumpled to the ground like the
way that these mages took out
the the soldiers but then you also had
fringilla who had this box and you're
like what's in the box turns out there
are these like mind-wielding little
metal uh
bugs
little slighty slimes that would slide
into the ear and then like she had
control over them so much different
magic so well done and to really ramp up
trisha's point on uh yennefer she cast
flame
so far and wide that she took out pretty
much the remainder of the nilfgaardian
army this episode had everything and it
ended on a cliffhanger
that made you want to have season two so
hard and that was the fact that geralt
and siri finally after eight episodes
meet up with one another and the first
thing that she says is who is jennifer
oh that is just beautiful so the finale
was the best one hands down yeah if
you're a dude that's not the first
question you want to hear you've been
waiting for this destiny moment for a
long time that is not the first question
you want to hear a lot of bugs going
into a lot of ears i believe vilgefortz
is the na it's
there's a lot of a lot of really
complicated names in there so let's just
let maud do some research on names and
we'll go to trisha for your minute
argument what's your best episode of
season one tricia i'm going with
banquets bastards and burials uh
burials i can talk today burials uh so i
absolutely adore this episode i feel
like this is a bit of an underdog answer
because anytime in a trilogy or in a
season when people say what's the best
episode everyone always goes for the
climax where all the timelines converge
and all the big stuff happens but i'm
going with the underdog here um i love
this episode because
and you know just throw to mods point
earlier about yaskir here we get to see
geralt and yaski are for one of the
first times where daryl actually gives
in and you peek through his cold heart
exterior and realize that he actually
kind of likes yester uh which is such a
beautiful moment when geralt agrees to
go and essentially be his bodyguard he's
going to a party to be asking his
bodyguard but if you're just following
the grunting up until then and you're
new to the series you're like wait hold
up what's even happening so we get this
beautiful glimpse into their friendship
in this episode that i love and i think
that friendship is so important to the
series and how they interact outside of
their typical bickering um this is also
the episode where we get to see
where
geralt's kind of law of morality if you
will what guides him we get to see this
in play now up until this point in the
series um i feel like we see a lot of
geralt being the monster hunter for hire
this is who he is and we start to see
things like you know he he's not for
hire for people and he starts to kind of
lay out his code for us but it's really
interesting when
in this episode he's specifically
sitting next to clampy and you watch his
banter with calampi he is not
uh you know he is not bowing to her when
she pushes him on issues he's not giving
in at all and we're slowly getting these
beautiful puzzle pieces of what geralt
stands for what makes him different than
maybe other witchers that they might
have encountered in this world
and when it comes down to it that moment
where he decides to jump into the battle
and side with dooney or our beautiful
lover hedgehog uh when he decides to
jump in and fight for dooney
and just completely disobey what queen
kalanthi wants him to do
that is ballsy and it speaks volumes
about who geralt is as our main
protagonist throughout this series um he
has his own set of standards right and
then that whole moment where he does
that and stands up for the law of
surprise and destiny um this is where we
set the stage for everything that is to
follow for geralt and series
relationship for when we find out about
geralt's mom later in season eight like
we're setting the stage for why destiny
is important
we find out here what is the law of
surprise should we care who does care
geralt cares and in that
in that moment we find out that pavetta
is then also pregnant so it's it's the
whole like oh oh my god like that it's
when everything like the bomb drops
everything goes off and everything is
set into motion speaking of pavetta when
we see her use her power in this episode
it informs so much about why siri is so
important to the series and i feel like
people who play the game know how
powerful cyrilla is but in this series
it's still kind of very like oh why is
siri important do we know this is the
episode where we see it through pavetta
we see what pavetta can do and then we
know
as as a viewer of the series you know
what siri could be capable of and i just
think it again it speaks volumes for
that um
and yeah i mean the the yen and queen
kayla's scene that i talked about at
length earlier happens in this episode
um and i do think that when yen finds
the moment that she has she has fought
so hard and
the child who she's decided to try to
save um still despite her best efforts
does not survive that encounter um i
think watching that that entire
transformation of do i even want to help
this woman to yes i'll help her because
it's my duty to know i actually am going
to be independent and screw her she's
been so mean to me but hold on this
baby's innocent
okay i'm gonna fight with everything i
can to save the baby to still have that
taken away from her is such a beautiful
complex moment for yennefer as well so
for many many reasons i think that of
banquets bastards and burials does not
deserve uh or does deserves a lot more
love
so i don't say that it normally
it's really the it's one of the first
times of the flower known as the witcher
series at least for me was in full bloom
and you really got a lot of story lines
that all started to make sense and
connect up and then you also have
episode 8 which is the final episode
which is the finale that did not
disappoint and made us very hungry for
season two so it's a tough call here mod
gary go back to you for a quick rebuttal
if you do any sort of research online
across the board this is the highest and
best rated episode episode eight the
finale uh so just from like a critical
point of view it is actually has already
been decided that it's the best uh
because we're not talking favorite here
we are talking best and so that will do
it the problem with of banquets bastards
and burials the issue that i had it's
actually really confusing the fact that
it comes in at episode four when we've
never met
parvati before um we've nev we've met
sorella
it doesn't really kind of aid the
timeline jump the law of surprise was a
lot of information at once when i first
saw that episode i finished it very
confused i felt that it didn't really
handle the mass amount of information at
the right particular time maybe it would
have been better suited for episode five
just having a little bit more history a
little bit more introduction to this new
era and it maybe it focused a little bit
too much on geralt instead of where we
were at with kalanthi's uh empire and
where sintra was i just felt that it if
you're looking at an arc this one kind
of dropped a little bit like it just
wasn't a smooth placement in the entire
arc this time around the second time
with subtitles on i was able to kind of
pick it up better but i'd also read the
book at this stage as well so i think
that actually harmed the episode uh more
than it uplifted it also it was really
confusing with dooney how was he cursed
was it the fact that he saved the king
was he uh porcupine at that stage as
well that was just an extra layer that
again wasn't really clear to me and it
was just a really confusing episode um
this episode again reminds me that i'm
consistently disappointed by kalanthi uh
any scene that she's in in this
particular episode is just like white
knuckled and also
i feel bad doing this but trisha as a
mother
how could you
have a favorite episode where a woman
kills a mother that she was trying to
protect to steal her child which still
again she does not kill the mother that
is a 100 straw man argument and i am
called sacrifice as a woman she didn't
sacrifice herself to save them she said
i'll give you the [ __ ] i'll give trisha
i'll give i'll hand trisha back the ball
so trisha you can't you can reply to
that to invoking the mom card however
you want to take it i played it i played
it
i mean
yes a child died in it just because i'm
a parent does not mean that i'm like
worst episode ever
as i explained previously i think that
jen went through a very very complex
series of emotions here and she did give
it her all to save that child so that
like playing the as a mother card thing
i feel like is 100
irrelevant it's very it's very very well
explained in both the book and the
series in my opinion so i would say
unless you like forgot and honestly not
just a chunk of the book but one of the
most important chunks of the book like
the law of surprise and destiny and
understanding what that is is integral
to understanding everything that happens
in the witcher so if you don't get that
part
that's not great
uh so to those of you out there if you
watched it and you were confused watch
it again it's it's in my opinion it is
not confusing what happens with dooney
dooney was cursed uh he was not a
hedgehog prior to being cursed he was
cursed to become a hedgehog and that's
why when daryl in the episode says this
is not a monster this is a cursed man
and it comes out that kalanthi knew that
the whole time which yes it's
frustrating as an audience member to
watch but i love the portrayal um i
think she does a great job showing a
very flawed character it's not how we as
the audience want her to react knowing
the information that we know
but that is that character and i think
she does a very good job of portraying
it um yeah i mean i i think i think that
knowing the the law
of knowing the destiny knowing the law
of surprise knowing how geralt gets his
child of surprise watching all of that
unfold before us
is fascinating and it's like it's like
the witcher 101 so you have to get that
part
hey everyone welcome back to binge
battle let's see more of what our guests
had to say about today's topic
okay
strong strong argument strong rebuttal
here and now we just have that time for
the final statement so it's it's got to
be quick but i know we're getting heated
here in your best episode this is not
the category i thought we were going to
get the most debate but man it's been a
good one so far so i do not know which
way to go i will say i encourage
everybody to watch the witcher with
subtitles if you're having trouble
because subtitles have been such a
godsend for so many people for a great
variety of reasons and i highly
encourage you you're watching something
like that subtitles can help uh let's go
to the final argument mon garrett you're
up first look i may be blonde uh but we
are talking about the show as a
standalone not having the information
from the book but just the show uh and
so i feel i feel like if you have to
watch an episode twice it's not the best
whether it was the position of the show
irrelevant not irrelevant it could be
that who knows you're talking about the
seed being planted i am talking about
the episode where everything blossoms
it's all full bloom it's not one element
of an entire show that's been introduced
it is all the things that have been
planted coming to fruition we are
talking about yen's discovery where for
the first time she does a selfless thing
and we see the full extent of her power
the whole time siri from episode one has
to find geralt of rivia she does in this
episode we see
sword fights we see nilfgaard trying to
take over and this small handful of
majors giving it everything that they've
got we explore new types of magic and
i'm the kind of fantasy lover that when
you drop these sorts of big boom spells
you're just sitting there holding your
face because it is so awesome it is the
most satisfying episode it is by far the
best one uh and it just ties it up so
nicely and then includes a cliffhanger
for season two which i'm excited for
it's the best episode all right you
heard it for mod garrett face holdingly
awesome so let's go to trisha
hershberger for your final argument
about episode four
i mean it is face-holdingly awesome it's
the season finale i feel like the season
finale is an easy grab anytime you're
asked in a season what's the best
episode everybody's gonna say watch the
first episode watch the last episode the
last episodes where it all culminates i
do feel like that's a given when i think
about the world of the witcher as a
whole again i'm going back to
understanding the law of surprise
understanding why destiny is important
understanding that siri is geralt's
destiny and all of that happens in this
episode plus i mean you want to talk
about super powerful hate face holding
magical moments pavetta freaking out
when the love of her life is about to
die and no one being able to do anything
about it
that's a face holding magic moment as
well um so i i feel like my strategy of
i don't want to tear down
mods answers because i also love that
part of the witcher i love all parts of
the witcher so i'm going into this just
saying that like this is what i love and
if everybody watching that agrees with
me then awesome because we're all fans
of the witcher
well we are always going to have mod
garrett to thank any time in the future
you see on a movie poster that this
movie's face-holdingly awesome we owe a
little thank you to maud garrett i am
going to make an interesting ruling here
because i do feel like episode 8 might
be the best for a relative newbie to the
witcher like myself for a lot of the
reasons that both mod and trisha
highlighted that you're watching the
series for the first time and you want
that huge climactic battle scene you
want that ooh will they won't they with
destiny but then you also have people
who've been fans of the witcher for
years if not decades and i think that
episode four might have had packed in
the most for them and so it's also
convenient that i now get to invoke my
own law of surprise by doing the
following we're a little short on time
here and so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to call this round a tie not
because i can't make a decision but
because i both feel like you argued
valiantly for your very separate points
and it also conveniently makes us tied
at to a piece as we head into what will
be the final round and it's gonna be a
quick one it's gonna be a speed round
and that is going to be round four here
we go we're tied up the best moment in
the show what is the best moment in the
witcher now here's how a speed round
works again because we're a little short
on time we each only have one minute to
make an argument then i have all the
pressure on myself and so it's ma
garrett it's trisha hershberger two of
my dear friends who love the witcher
series as well as a lot of the fair that
inspired it so i'm gonna go with you
first trisha you get to argue for your
favorite moment in the show or you can
define it as best moment that's totally
up to you you have a minute or less
okay i'm a huge sucker for awesome fight
choreography so i'm going with the
geralt versus renfree fight in episode
one um this fight had us on the edge of
our seat it was so glorious to watch
action fans coming from the games are
gonna feel right at home here the shots
were fantastic there were long
continuous shots that seemed to go on
forever mixed with expert choreo and
hand-to-hand combat and quick dynamic
camera movements that 360 degree shot of
geralt just swatting away the crossbow
arrows showed us how quick and what a
formidable fighter he really is then he
takes down all of renfree's men we find
out how he became the butcher of
blavican which is the most tragic title
ever because he didn't want to do it
he didn't want to fight we don't want to
watch renfree and geralt battle it out
to the death but that's what ends up
happening and it sets the scene to tell
us that this world of the witch or the
continent it's a world that is not fair
and really dark stuff happens and it
entap it establishes the entire setting
for the show plus gives us the action
that everyone's coming for looking for
like a dark fantasy adventure series
renfrey wants him to choose the lesser
of two evils right she was ready to die
to convince geralt to kill striker for
her and when he won he gave her the
chance to walk away
and she still wouldn't do it he knew it
was going to be him or her he had to do
it and then he lives with the title the
butcher of blavican forever
forever okay that is trisha
hershberger's argument and that's all
the time she gets so now mod garrett
you're on the clock for the round that
will determine the match have that at
your best moment
jennifer's transformation
is the pinnacle of the show for so many
reasons but let's just take into
consideration yennefer obviously because
apparently she was cursed with her
quarter elf blood she was a hunchback
she had a jaw deformity she was bullied
she was ridiculed she was sold by her
father for less than the price of a pig
she was bought by tasaya to study in
mage arts to learn about magic she not
only progresses through college but she
gets a taste of being good enough for
the first time ever i will say a
highlight for me especially for the
disabled community is that she found a
lover in her original um uh you know
with her state which i think celebrates
sort of disability in a particular way
the problem with jennifer though is that
she gets a taste of power and she cannot
stop and she wants more and she
sacrifices literally her fertility
organs to try and have you know a chance
at this she realizes that she needs to
look perfect because as a woman you need
to to have any kind of understanding and
placement in politics the way that the
transformation takes place though is so
stunning because you have someone who is
literally using paint onto her body like
an artist to
re-configurate and to re-mold her into
it so when you see her before and when
you see her walk away after it's a very
different person and that confidence
that comes with it is when jennifer's
arc just hits the ground running and you
see her vulnerability in that moment her
pain can't be numbed she has to take on
all of the agony to get through to the
other side i will say that with um the
geralt versus rainfree i prefer it where
if geralt's going to fight a woman it's
a striga and actually he ended up saving
her and he killed a woman in that moment
so for me not my favorite moment but i'm
going to go yen's transformation because
it is actually woman empowerment
all right so it's all unfair that mod
snuck in a rebuttal
we can
we can have the court disavow
i play the feminist god too strike that
from the record well look i'm going to
feel awful regardless of who i uh who i
rule for here because i i i feel both of
these moments were so
integral to the show because you have
one moment where it's the full
realization of a character where mod's
talking about with the transformation
but then you also have the fight the
battle deep fight that initiates us into
the show and i think we're kind of even
there because a lot of folks like me are
looking for that epic
thing to see in the very first episode
that's going to get us hooked on for the
rest of time and then we also meet
jennifer and we see what even just
watching the show today i'm sure a lot
of people realize just what a complex
person whose personality you can really
see it depends on what prism you're
looking at it through who this figure
really is in the war and so i think that
where my point lies here is that
the fight between
geralt and renfree it was so well done
and it also introduced us to the show
jennifer's transformation then also gave
us such deep knowledge and mythology to
who that character is and everything
that she's gone through so i think the
tiebreaker here for me goes to the fact
that i mean like literally as renfree's
you know the last thing that renfree's
able to convey is that there is this
person in the woods that's about destiny
and you just hear that and you're like
oh my god what are we what are we in for
here and it just it became tangible and
it became something for viewers to seek
after for the rest of season one and so
by the thinnest of margins after two
face-holding arguments i think i'm gonna
have to give it to trisha hershberger
here for the point and trisha after what
christian rubicon and i've been through
a lot of these binge battles now this
has been the this has been the hardest
spot this has been the one where the
gloves came off but look we're still
friends at the end of it i hope i can
say that your champion today is tricia
hershberger but you're both fantastic
warriors in my book so trisha you have
the honor to let everybody know the
stuff you're working on right now and
some streaming recommendations for
everybody we might have some time off
coming up here soon so what are some
shows some movies do you think the folks
need to check out
we love the witcher um the things i
would say to check out uh i'm watching
wheel of time right now if you're into
fantasy um and mod i know you have read
these books yeah i actually have not
read these books yet so i'm coming into
this series as someone who's not read
the books and i'm fully in i'm totally
caught up i'm fully in the pilot i feel
like was a little rough so get through
the pilot but then after that i feel
like you're gonna be super hooked um
arcane is good i'm not fully caught up
on that and i'm watching marvel's
hawkeye marvel's hawkeye is a delightful
christmas romp y'all get on in that if
you have some time um so thank you guys
so much for having me those are the
things that i'm watching and uh yeah
that's what you asked right was there
another part to your question
well everybody can find on social media
at that girl trish just take the eye out
of grl right that girl trish and that's
where that's where you can follow uh
trisha on all her many exploits through
the world of gaming and tech and
entertainment and so now we have mod
garrett who is simply at mod garrett on
most social media platforms mod
you you did come out on top as far as
i'm concerned today it's just that
trisha was the champion don't worry
about any of that just focus on how much
fun you had today and some streaming
recommendations and what you're working
on streaming recommendations i've gotten
back into anime big time i'm watching my
hero academia i've watched five seasons
and two three movies in two weeks uh i
can't come up for air it was a real
struggle to actually come onto this show
because i can't stop watching it um so
any anime wrecks please hit me up i'm in
big time i'm gonna watch i'm going to
the theater to watch the latest movie
and i'm so excited about that also with
wheel of time uh fantastic i love it
they are condensing big time and it
really actually helps the the tv show um
the books are a mission
but rosamond pike actually narrates the
audible version and it's because of the
release of the show and she is a godsend
so if you want to try and listen to the
book that is how i would recommend doing
it if you're into it big time and also
arcane
is has revolutionized video game media
becoming a different medium completely
that is the creator and owner of
geekbomb mod garrett you have trisha
hershberger here is our champion today
if you haven't seen the witcher and you
watch this episode you still have a lot
more in store for you there's a whole
lot of twists and turns and surprises
that series takes and from what i'm
hearing the books and the short stories
in the games and all of that takes so i
welcome everybody to get deeper into the
world of the witcher make sure that you
are following on garrett and trisha
hershberger wherever they have their
next fun exploits and coverage and all
the great things that they're doing in
this fun community that does it for our
show today here on binge battle for
everybody here at rotten tomatoes our
expert engineer christian rubicaba i am
merely mark ellis saying thanks and if
we're about to get into the holiday
season happy holidays everyone and to
all a good night let's hold some faces
we'll work on that out
bring it on